you did this kind of archaeological dig
into the history of
you know the united states and its
relationship with swimming
and in particular you know pool building
and access to pools
and how that changed over time so let's
talk about that a little bit because i i
think it's
it's it's pretty interesting i know like
i grew up in the northeast
and you know most high schools don't
have
pools whereas in other parts of the
country they do
and that tracks back to our you know
sort of checkered relationship with
with race and segregation yeah i
i really did not appreciate meaning i
didn't understand
um the extent to which
the current um
you know gap the racial gap in swimming
ability between
especially blacks and whites in this
country
is so traced back to
this era of segregation um in our
country
and it that it the fact that it persists
to the degree that it does
i mean i think the rate is that um the
latest statistics show that
um black kids are five times they drown
at a rate five times out of white
children
right i mean that is just
terr it's horrible and i um
you know and then it's not just uh
swimming
access and education but it's also then
when you break through to join a team
you find a team you're swimming you love
it
and then you feel like you're the only
one or you're the
you're you know swimming remains a very
white sport
um and you don't feel welcome or you
don't feel
um that you belong or that you have
positive images and and
and stories uh i i think that that
that has a really profound effect on
whether you want to keep doing something
you know so like i was
i recently got to talk to
the founders of an organization called
black hit swim and
ebony roseman was the is the founder and
she was talking about how when her
daughter
started swimming um
and then i think the reason they started
the organization is because when
they googled like black kids swim they
would they would
come up with um the the top google hits
were
like black people can't swim or black
kids don't know how to swim
when i was growing up as a kid there was
this trope like oh well you know
black kids can't swim right they have a
higher density body density or something
like that like some crazy
reason why black people weren't good at
swimming
right it's just ridiculous and then that
is pervasive and it persists and that's
you know those are the like ridiculous
things that i heard growing up too
um at the same time um i think of my
experience um you know as you uh
pointed to was really special for me
because i
grew up um i swam on a team that was in
the next town over and it was a very
diverse community
um freeport new york is you know uh
has a large african-american and latino
demographic and it also the team also
attracted kids from all
across long island and you know even
though
i was at one of the you know the
quote-unquote the onlys in my high
school
a town away two towns away uh that pool
was super diverse you know the head
guard uh
you know the at that pool where i
lifeguarded the freeport
rack was um was black you know and she
i don't know i think to see my point is
to
be able to see representation around you
is no small thing i really
um credit that experience
with i mean making me who i am today
yeah
you know the uh the section in the book
where you talk about this era
you know in the 1910s and early 1920s
when
america was building these massive
public pools right we've all seen
pictures of that extraordinary pool in
san francisco that just looked like
a football yeah i think there was one in
chicago too there were a couple
of these gigantic you know glass
ceiling you know like they look like
arboretums almost that were
gigantic that went the way of the dodo
right like they just disappeared yeah
they were
so this was a shift in um public pools
from being um you know during the
progressive area there were there were
pools for like
before that was public hygiene you know
like they were actually bathing
facilities so like working class and
immigrants
would go and men would go on alternating
days with from women
and um so so it was
much more a gender split
with these pools and then once they
became what you described these like
pool palaces basically like pools then
public pools were then for
recreation and so then were for families
and were
then um you know public
authorities you know the sentiment was
that
people of color could not swim in these
pools with white people
and so there were they were turned away
from a lot of pools
um there were um you know and then
during the civil rights era the
the public the pool spaces the watery
spaces the
even public beaches that they were sites
of
protest and
in the book i talk about how there was
this incident
called a bloody sunday was like in
at a public beach in mississippi and
it's it's where
blacks went to be
you know to use this public beach and
and there you know there were riots and
and many of these
pools um that happened there was
violence um and
and if you think about it we're talking
about how water is freedom water is
relief
water is so universal to all of us as
humans
and yet this essential
um this essential thing was not
available to everyone
um and and i think the right of leisure
the right
of recreation was something that was was
seen
as um symbolic of this fight for equal
rights and equity
yeah and so ultimately these pool
palaces
close down they just shudder right and
then hence begins
this movement towards the backyard pool
so the public pool
kind of you know isn't a primary focus
anymore because it's complicated for
those reasons yeah
after desegregation you know you'd think
that
the fight is you know is over you know
equality won but actually um a lot of
whites
then you know of means like fled
the public community rules and pull you
know
built their own backyard pools and
you'll see this
you know in california it's interesting
right because california especially
southern california is such a an
epicenter for this
backyard pool culture and it's this
beautiful
i mean you look at these photos of like
palm springs and la
and um it is such a
it is this very golden light um perfect
um visual history and yet where are the
black people you know where are the
people
of color in these records and um and i
think that that
that is being rewritten and and pushed
at and
and you know that that uh beautiful
bubble is being punctured
in a way that is um starting to be in
in in a way that is really important to
our understanding of what those images
actually meant it meant exclusion
right it feels it feels like
there's still some way to go though
because oh yeah the country is littered
with these public works pools
that are all over the place many of
which sit
drained right and empty like that pool
in central park at the north end of the
park that massive pool like most of the
time
there's no water in that pool like there
seems to be a lot of
um establishments like that all over the
place that either
because they lack funding or for
whatever reason that i'm
unfamiliar with they just don't they
don't they're not really
you know they're like in disrepair yeah
it's really expensive to maintain a pool
and um what i learned in this pandemic
period i was reporting a story
about a reopening of a public pool in my
neighborhood and i learned that most
municipal pools you know the public
pools that are run by cities
uh operate at a deficit even in normal
times
so they're hemorrhaging money and that
the season in which they would take in
revenue is
the summer you know camps and um
all like swimming lessons and swim teams
and for this
entire year they they did not have any
of that
and so now they're even more in the hole
and so now
as as many pools have struggled to
reopen
in some limited fashion right so but
think about it it's
one lane per person uh
spaced out if they were losing money
before
hate to think about what it means
because um
the sad fact is a lot of these pools um
will not reopen you know even after the
pandemic and so
that to me is
i mean it's hard to stomach because that
means then another generation of
of kids might not get right what we had
you know
um and that's just really it's hard i i
think
about you know in in the course of
researching this book
uh i learned that swimming education
is universal it's part of the public
school education in so many other
countries and i think
that would be amazing you know if that
were the case in this country it would
make
such a difference